in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some middleware pros with
their BigTable performance will we
upgrade to the latest version of
Awesomeness stay tuned to find out for a
company like time sliders time series
data is the backbone of their business
model but lately it's been the bane of
their users their main product is a
performance instrumentation library the
developers can add to their mobile apps
to get runtime data from the field sadly
this process of building and displaying
performance tables in the report web
pages quickly became a bottleneck and a
less than ideal experience for the
majority of their clients thankfully we
didn't have to look too far to find the
problem time stamps see every 100
milliseconds or so their library would
log the battery status creating an entry
into a big table where the row key
consisted of the word battery plus a
timestamp now while this seems like a
straightforward implementation it runs
into a problem with hot spotting I see
when a row key for a time series
includes a timestamp then all of your
rights will target a single node it'll
fill that node and then move on to the
next node in the cluster filling that
node and so on this pattern creates
scenarios where performance suffers for
your application addressing this
problems means leveraging the concept of
field promotion ah--this trick involves
moving fields from the column data into
the row key to make writes
non-contiguous for example time sliders
ended up promoting the user ID value
from a column to an element of the row
key this change solved their hot
spotting issue because of the fact that
the identifier for users provided a more
uniform distribution of row keys
splitting rights across multiple nodes
in the cluster reducing hot spotting and
improving performance
now in case field promotion doesn't work
for you then check out the article
linked in the description below where we
cover a few other alternatives likewise
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great cloud performance
Atlas content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts
[Music]